Never hit an animal.
They cannot speak, but are living beings just like us.
They can get just as hurt as you and I.
If you find an injured animal near your home,...
...see what you can do to help.
Leave seeds for birds in your garden.
Make a bird house in your yard and don't forget to add a bird bath.
Water bodies are home to fish and some other animal species.
Don't throw trash in ponds, lakes and other water bodies.
Plant shrubs and other flowering plants for butterflies and bees in your garden.
If you have a pet at home, make sure you keep it and its surroundings clean.
Take your pet to a pet doctor for a checkup when it's sick.
And also for proper vaccinations.